drôle d'atmosphère en effet autour du
canal saint martin il rentre dans la
dernière phase de son nettoyage avant le
démarrage des travaux de maçonnerie et
de remblayage en attendant il faut
encore récurer et enlever la base on
assiste en même temps à une drôle de
pêche un véritable inventaire à la
prévert
leur but les nettoyer tour qui ont ils
trient pas sur un imprimé à tous et du
verre plastique tout dû faire les gens
jettent n'importe quoi et des sièges des
valises pour des scooters de n'importe
quoi
les objets sont cependant moins nombreux
que lors de la dernière mise à sec en
1993 ou 40 tonnes de déchets avaient été
récoltés sur quatre kilomètres et demi
le chantier est impressionnant plusieurs
centaines de personnes y travaillent les
ouvriers du service des canaux de la
ville de paris mais aussi une quinzaine
d'entreprises privées